if I ask you the funniest word in the
world you probably say like I don't know
queef or taint or diarrhea mama mia
which is secondly hyphenated or diarrhea
queef taint but you'd be wrong
a pair of researchers in the University
of Warwick of scientifically determine
the funniest would the English language
and they are thusly booty tit and booby
it turns out we didn't need comedy
writers we just needed a calculator guys
the study also identified the unfunniest
words which include teeth torture in
context of what I'm saying is funny cuz
there's such horrible words torture
nightmare and trauma which are really
funny in this context I mean diseases
not in any other context but next to
blue beat it and booty so researchers
say these words aren't funny but you're
all professional comedians kids in the
halls very inspirational to me are
legendary comic entities I would like
you to was I going to pick one of these
supposedly unfunny words and make it
funny Kevin
nightmare because once I had a nightmare
that I was naked in the school but when
I woke up I was just making in front of
a school kid all right book got
something well I'm gonna obviously go
with torture sure mom Chris um I pull
disclosure yeah I like it a little I
like a little rough okay as you know and
as these gentlemen know yes which is why
I don't think torture would work on me I
wouldn't start talking till at least
electricity alright yeah
stapling war kids
[Laughter]